a cool thing to bring to the surface is
how guys bond by showing their dicks
that's still disgusting their chicks do
with each other yeah
oh you don't go like hey you want to see
a loaf of bread and try to squeeze your
titties
is that why women aren't as close as men
are women you guys are more comfortable
with showing each other your physical
with baked goods yeah like it's a mature
and fine how much someone was calling
you FaceTime you go like this and then
you answer it that's not funny to women
I mean it's funny to me I think chicks
in the WNBA are like that
maybe there's a higher chance that
there's more WNBA people have that same
defect we do I did experience this we
were at a party we were like in this
room there was a mirror and there's like
a few girls in that room and she just
takes off her top she's looking at her
boobs and I want them to be more like
this and this I've I've seen that like
it's like yeah but it's never in like
but it's constructive I would love to
see like a woman lady you'd be like look
at my hamburger
yeah like as a joke